le vaches sont une des choses pour
combattre les changements climatiques
on peut pas manger du boeuf à la
quantité qu'on fait présentement on
l'est vivent sur la grotte l'apl dernier
cinquante années 80 ça existe plus on le
sait le boeuf ces polluants les
canadiens produits 716 millions de
tonnes d'équivalent co2 par année on
estime que 12 % est attribuable au
secteur agricole si on considère les
combustibles fossiles utilisées par
l'industrie
le tiers des émissions de l'agriculture
provient du méthane émis par les
ruminants qui digère pour produire un
kilogramme de boeuf vivant au canada on
va générer l'équivalent de 10 kg de co2
c'est cinq fois plus que pour le port
dix foix plus que pour le poulet sa
chance
est ce que c'est possible de manger du
boeuf sans sentir coupable la majorité
des bovins au québec sont nourris avec
des céréales comme le maïs le grain
c'est plus caloriques que l'herbe donc
les vaches grandissent plus vite au
québec 90% du grain qu'on produit est
destiné aux animaux
plusieurs producteurs de grains vont
labourer leurs terres et quand on
laboure le sol voire acheter du gaz
carbonique dans l'atmosphère
beaucoup utilisent des engrais comme la
zot pour enrichir leur sol et quand on
utilise trop d'azoté les microorganismes
du sol se met à produire du protoxyde
d'azoté
ça c'est du gaz hilarant mais dans ce
cas ci c'est pas drôle le protoxyde
d'azoté
ces 300 fois plus puissant que le gaz
carbonique en termes de réchauffement
climatique
on est présentement en route vers saint
andré avellin c'est en outaouais pour
ceux qui savent fossé où on savoir
rencontrer paul slam qui est un éleveur
et produits du boeuf en pâturage il dit
que son boeuf est tellement performant
qui serait même carboneutre
[Musique]
attention au dessus marche trop tard
mais selon lui ces polices l'homme sur
sa ferme y élève 200 vaches et si on lui
dit qu'elles sont polluantes d'un lui il
pense plutôt au contraire pour moi le
vaches sont une des choses pour
combattre les changements climatiques
c'est rare qu'on entend ça des vaches
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques
ça c'est la terre de paul sur laquelle
vivent ces vaches toute l'année elle
reste dehors tout le temps elles se
nourrissent exclusivement terme
mais au lieu de les laisser brouter où
elles veulent pas lui utilise une
technique appelée le pâturage adaptatifs
à enclos multiples en gros sa terre est
divisé en quarante parcelles plusieurs
fois par jour il déplace son troupeau
il lui fait faire une migration la
technique s'inspire des migrations
effectué par les bisons les vaches
élèves travaillent ensemble pour prendre
le carbone dans l'air mais c'est pas
vraiment les vaches qui fait ça c'est
les plantes donc sur le sol
on a les feuilles de plantes qui
poussent et dans le sol qu'on allait
rasées dans leur rotation les vaches
mangent en partie les blancs mais pas
trop elles doivent rester en vie voilà
pourquoi il faut que la rotation soit
bien fait
après avoir été brouter les végétaux
utilise l'énergie de leurs racines pour
stimuler la croissance de nouvelles
feuilles grâce à la photosynthèse
ses feuilles 4 le gaz carbonique et le
transforme en glucose tout en renvoyant
de l'oxygène dans l'air une portion du
glucose va ensuite servir à développer
le système racinaire une partie des
racines vont mourir et devenir du
carbone séquestré dans le sol c'est une
des formes de calmants plus stables dans
le monde sait les anciens racines qui
reste juste dans le sol avec sept cycles
d'herbe et les racines on peut mettre
plus de carbone dans le sol que les
vaches peuvent produire avec le métal on
va s'entendre le discours de paul c'est
loin d'être la norme
plusieurs études ont démontré que les
vaches au pâturage peuvent être plus
polluante que celle qui grandissent dans
les parcs d'engraissement parce qu'elles
se nourrissent d'herbe un aliment qui
est moins calorique le grain les vaches
au pâturage ont besoin de plus de temps
pour atteindre un poids commercial
elles vont donc émettent du méthane plus
longtemps mais secret ce serait les
rotations qui permet à l'herbe de jouer
son rôle
c'est le gestion de pâturage qui est
important on peut pas juste l'esl et les
animaux
dans un champ d'herbe est retourné dans
trois mois et avoir une explication de
mettet carbone dans le sol dont on vient
de prendre la route on retourne vers
montréal parce qu'on s'en va rencontrer
un boucher que décidé de se spécialiser
là dedans dans le boeuf éco-responsable
et s'appelle pascal leboucher pascal est
ce que c'est possible de manger du
beurre sans sentir coupable on peut pas
manger du boeuf à la quantité et qu'on
fait présentement c'est pour ça qu'il
faut drastiquement réduire notre
quantité de boeuf et de viande qu'on
mange mais quand on en mange de
s'assurer que sa vie de petite
production qui sont dans une rotation
intensive qui sont dans une zone
équilibre la ferme qui sont en synergie
avec la production maraîchère exemple
sur la ferme pour revenir un peu à ces
petits qui les bloque on s'est éloigné
avec la production intensive est
automatiquement lorsqu'on parle de plus
petites productions
les clients vont devoir payer plus cher
qui a pas l'économie d'échelle qui vient
avec
c'est sûr ils vont vraiment vouloir
donner une alimentation qui est adapté
aux besoins de l'animal ils vont pas
utiliser des intrants pour que les
animaux grand 6 grandissent plus vite
ils vont donner beaucoup d'espacé aux
animaux donc et donc ont bougé donc tout
ça prend plus de temps plus d'énergie
pour arriver au même poids carcasse que
quelque chose de conventionnel
donc oui c'est vrai que ça va se
refléter au prix à la fin sauf que pour
moi c'est le vrai coût de ce que ça
représente de manger de la viande
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu souhaites que les
clients passent dans l'ordre dans leur
consommation bien ta qui pose des
questions vraiment savoir d'où ça vient
de s'informer qu'est ce qu'ils mangent
de se rapprocher de ceux qui produisent
des aliments quand on sait d'où ça vient
on crée de la valeur on s'attache à nos
aliments le président est un petit peu
trop déconnecté notre alimentation de
notre agriculture il faut se rapprocher
de ça mais c'est en faisant des
activités agrotouristiques ou en
s'informant en se rapprochant nos
producteurs que si ça peut faire partie
de la solution
[Musique]
on a quitté montréal on se dirige vers
des fournisseurs de pascal leboucher
croyons mme malone et qui est considéré
par plusieurs comme le pionnier de
l'élevage de boeuf à l'herbe au québec
aujourd'hui reçoit une quarantaine de
personnes dont un peu partout dans la
province ces personnes souhaitent en
savoir un petit peu plus 67 d'élevage
pour moi aujourd'hui est ce crédit on
travaille dans les jours comme ça tout
le temps tu vas avoir l'expérience avec
nous aujourd'hui et c'est parti d'un des
petits lapins et des barres fly
alentours la perle et au gré des goûts
red bull
quand on visite la ferme de brian et
nous parle beaucoup de ses vaches mais
sur tout son sol depuis 40 ans y'a lève
ses vaches en pâturages avec l'objectif
de séquestrer du carbone est lui aussi
convaincu que les bovins ont un rôle à
jouer non seulement pour limiter les
changements climatiques mais aussi pour
enrichir les sols
votre salaire deux fois ici c'est quoi
sa santé on estime que les sols
agricoles du québec ont en moyenne 5 %
de matières organiques et cette
proportion est en baisse constante
depuis des années et on est capable de
sentir quelque chose entre une empilade
c'est vivant qui est du mas ça c'est les
les maisons de les vers de terre qui
fait la futilité pour nous le sol et
fret les veines des traits travaille
encore
ma démarche y travaillent vous mettez
pas d'engrais vous labouré peau vous
mettez pas de semences comme les bisons
rien inventé la le modèle est là
tout ce que j'ai appris ce mon métier
est basé sur les bisons les ruminants
ils ont créé une planète qui est
empreint santé il ya des troupeaux
existant qui est à 20 km de l'âge 50 km
de long un tube oh il y avait pas de
problème de méthode au fond vous avez
l'impression que la nature sont un peu
votre modèle totalement total n'en ont
pas besoin d'aller plus loin que les
bisons 10 mai l'an passé gerald leurs
troupeaux heumann et chaque année ça
marche bien
jusqu'au temps que l'homme arrivé sur
situation puis de bison nature bizot
l'herbe des pieds à terre c'est cindy
ory c'est quelque chose qui va tout
ensemble on a du sol qui est rendue
presque pauvre maintenant au québec
oui le ter était crevé faire ça pour une
cinquantaine année là c'est fini
puis c'est pas compliqué on prend que ce
qu'on a besoin on retourne au sol vont
être bons pour les prochaines santé il
ya des centaines et des centaines presse
à hong lei vivent sur la grotte l'hôtel
dernier cinquante années le fatah
hollande c'est existe plus matières
organiques et baisser en lève juste un
peu moins retenu au sol puis on va
corriger des situations
la première philosophie c'est cheap les
i je veux pas travailler et je veux pas
trop dépenser l'argent si les animaux
sont capables d'aller au champ et
récolté quelque chose moi j'ai pas
besoin travailler s'ils sont capables
aller d'un chien puis déposés là fumier
mais j'ai pas besoin le chevalier fumier
qui peinent l'asie la grosse brute avec
les têtes blanches
c'est la ligne on le garde juste parce
que j'appelle l avance tout le monde le
suit et les chanceux qui ai fait ça bien
sinon f érable as assiste depuis
longtemps
définition d'un pnr c'est celui qui est
des flèches dando tranquillement alors
des gens à lèvres des flèches noter si
on veut suivre des modèles
on est juste aussi bon que la moyenne
mais est ce que ton objectif d'un vie
c'est aussi bon que la moyenne
donc le boeuf est diabolisé par certains
pour d'autres c'est la solution pour
mieux comprendre on se rend à ottawa
pour rencontrer un chercheur qui se
spécialise dans le calcul de l'empreinte
carbone des produits agricoles voici
raymond desjardins colauréat du prix
nobel de la paix en 2007 pour ses
contributions aux travaux du giec et
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on a la
chance de rencontrer un prix nobel
on s'envoie des sympômes écossais pour
manger un vg burger sauver est-ce qu'on
devrait sans ces coupables de manger du
boeuf on dort pas sentir coupable
complètement parce que le boeuf sa place
parce qu'on a des prairies et le beurre
si des soldats ni mac pour convertir les
âmes à des protéines
alors pour sentir complètement cnam mais
faut il penser un peu parce que des
émissions des animaux qui ne baisse à
l'échelle globale
il pesait environ 14 14 points 5 % des
gaz à effet de serre sur la planète se
plaindre du boeuf carboneutre pensez
quoi
c'était bon bonnes ambitions il ya des
gens qui ont écrit une petite coupe de
publications aux états unis qui disent
que c'est très très bon là proches de me
dit papa doc
nous on a fait des études où on a vu des
bonnes relations entre le montant
d'animaux puis la séquence station
carbone et cette frustration carbone
équivaut environ à 400 kg de co2
équivalent par année
un beau vin produit en moyenne de 1200
kg de co2 qui balaie effectivement en
france nous autres en moyenne au canada
est pas vain sur les prairies émettre
environ 800 au lieu de 2200 parce que
une cause la séparation carbon monocell
800 kilogrammes d'équivalent co2 par
année au lieu de deux mille deux cents
c'est peut-être pas carbo neutre mais
c'est mieux que rien des études
américaines ont démontré que les
systèmes de pâturage adaptatif un enclos
multiples aurait le potentiel
d'atteindre une carboneutralité du moins
de séquestrer une quantité importante de
carbone dans le sol pour compenser le
méthane produit par les vaches
mais ces études ne sont pas faites dans
le contexte canadien je pense que nous
sommes quatre fermes au québec qui fait
ça nous sommes au début de cette système
c'est tout nouveau et avec notre
observation on commence voir vraiment
différent mais qu'est ce qu'il manque
c'est les universités qui faire les
recherches sur nos fermes port dit oui
ça fonctionne et nos recettes pratiques
fonctionne pas vraiment mais on peut
l'améliorer avec ça selon l'équipe de
recherche de raymond desjardins les
organisations de santé recommandent en
moyenne aux canadiens de se limiter à 20
kg de viande rouge cuite par année 6 et
20 kg et est constitué de 25 % peuvent
de pâturage et de 75% port 7,7 millions
tonnes d'équivalent co2 seraient
retranchés sur le bilan annuel de
l'agriculture
c'est près de 10% des émanations du
secteur qu'est ce que les canadiens
devraient faire comme changement dans
leur alimentation diminué montant de
aucun d'eux est pensé pour sa question
de protéines bonnes choses à penser
c'est pas le problème des créatures
c'est un problème de consommateurs que
des gens sont pas prêtes à payer le vrai
prix que ça coûte pour faire un bon
agriculture et des fois long et d'objets
investi dans
l'alimentation et on n'a pas besoin
manger beaucoup mes manches de bonne
qualité j'ai déjà entendu dire il faut
que je considérais comme en guerre
les changements climatiques et regardez
tous des solutions potentielles et il y
en a beaucoup dans cette période écoles
pour faire baisser le rideau
[Musique]